There are a lot of ways that this marvelous language of ours, English, doesn't make sense.
For example, most of the time, when we talk about more than one of something,...
...we put an "s" on the end.
One cat, two cats.
But then, there's that handful of words where things work differently.
Alone, you have a man; If he has company, then you've got men,...
...or probably better for him, women too.
Although, if there were only one of them, it would be a woman.
Or if there's more than one goose, they're geese,...
...but why aren't lots of "mooses" "meese"?
Or if you have two feet, then why don't you read two "beek" instead of books?
The fact is that if you were speaking English before about a thousand years ago,...
..."beek" is exactly what you would have said for more than one book.
If modern English is strange, Old English needed therapy.
Believe it or not, English used to be an even harder language to learn than it is today.